making a difference for our veterans
there was an event today to help our
military that's in need Mary Jane
beliesa explains what the veterans Stand
Down offers
there's so many opportunities here it's
endless crowds of veterans made their
way to the Silver Nugget Casino event
center chairperson Shalamar Cabrera says
the event is designed to have every
resource a veteran might need on hand in
one location everything from basic needs
services like food high
hours but all the way up to same day
housing if they're homeless employment
on the spot legal assistance child
support assistance plenty of Community
Partners also donating their time like
CC navred with Optum medicine we
transport veterans and so this was
definitely a perfect event for us to be
a part of and give back to the community
the transition from military life to a
civilian may not always be easy many
having difficulty during the pandemic
when they couldn't access the help they
needed
this it really shows that we haven't
forgotten the service and the sacrifice
of veterans right after being on a brief
pause due to covid organizers from the
veterans Stand Down events say the
biggest need they see now from military
veterans is financial assistance and
employment so many different resources
here is it's hard to fathom
I mean you don't know which way to go
Marine Corps veteran Joseph McDermott
heard about the event through U.S vets I
have a case manager there she
recommended I come down here today and
uh get help with my resume
and find employment veterans stepped up
when our country called now that they're
in need we need to be here for them
now the veterans Stand Down event has
helped over 200 veterans in just one day
across our Valley